The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So today, we're
going to get into innovation
at the institutional level.
So that's our fundamental topic.
Because we've been
out for two weeks,
let me do a recap so that we're
all current with the underlying
framework.
Class 1, we talked about, as
you remember, growth theory,
and we read Robert Solow
and Solow taught us
that technological and
related innovation is
the dominant causative
factor in economic growth.
Old classical economics posited
that it was capital supplier
labor supply.
Those remain important, but
the monster in the room,
Solow found, to the
tune of 60% or more,
is technological and
related innovation.
We also read Paul Romer.
And Paul Romer
says, wait a minute.
It's not just having
an R&D system.
You've got to staff
that R&D system.
It's the talent base.
That's a key driver.
That's another critical factor.
So his phrase is quote, "human
capital engaged in research."
So if you train great physicists
and they're driving cabs,
they're not engaged
in research, right?
That's a no-net gain.
But if they're engaged in that
system, that's what's critical.
And his prospector
theory says the size
of a well-qualified talent
base makes a huge difference.
That's a key driver.
Talent on task and a
lot of talent on task
is better than less
talent on task.
So those are two fundamental
innovation factors
that we arrived at
in the first class.
Class number 2,
we began thinking
about innovation systems.
So we got two factors
out of the first class.
Then we began to
think about systems.
Nelson tells us that there are
national systems of innovation
that you can analyze,
innovation at the systems level,
and look at the
actors in that system
and the strength of the
actors and therefore
the strength of
the whole system.
So that gives us a
third innovation factor,
which is really--
we'll call it
innovation organization.
And then we read some
other pieces in there.
I'll highlight a couple.
Don Kash and Robert
Rycroft said, you've
got to network the actors.
It's the network, the strength
of the network of the actors,
that's now, particularly
in a 21st century context,
particularly critical.
And we also read Charles
Schulze, a noted economist
from the University
of Minnesota,
who was a senior governmental
official in the Lyndon Johnson
era and then Jimmy Carter era.
And he raises the issue
of what's the public role?
What's the private role as we
look at innovation systems?
What should the public
function be versus
what the private
sector should be.
An absolutely fundamental
set of issues.
So then we did classes 3 and 4.
We essentially focused on
the innovation challenge
ahead in production.
And in class 3, we looked
at the kind of history
of US manufacturing problems.
We read Kent Hughes,
and he explains
the fascinating competition
when Japan launches
a brilliant new innovation
system and production
around quality.
That's where the
rust belt begins.
That's where US statistics
about growing inequality begin.
That's where this problem
that we're now worse off at,
that's where it commences.
And then we looked
at Korea and Japan
and how they built
manufacturing-led innovation
systems.
And then in class 4, we looked
at the current US manufacturing
problems.
So I wanted to put a set
of real issues, really
timely critical issues, kind
of on the table, if you will,
at the very beginning of the
class so that we're not--
you know, this is not a
class about abstraction.
These are real issues
that are extremely
timely in the way in which
society operates and functions.
And the US built a
comparative advantage
around its R&D system.
It did not organize around
manufacturing-led innovation
like Japan, Germany, Korea,
Taiwan, China, and so on.
We missed that
organizational step,
and we are continuing
to pay a price for that.
So we talked some two weeks
ago about David Autor and some
of his absolutely
fascinating work
on the decline of
US manufacturing
and the effect on
the labor force.
He has a new piece
out that talks
about the effect on innovation
of the intense competition
with China.
And essentially,
what he finds is
that firms that go up against
head-on-head competition
over a particular
product line with China
have to slash their innovation
capability, their R&D
capability, in order
to stay in the game.
But that kills them long term.
So that this
competition with Japan
is not only having an
effect on the labor market,
but it's also having a big
effect on the innovation
capability of companies.
And then we talked about
whether advanced manufacturing
could bring a new paradigm
to the table, where
US developing countries can
kind of get back in the game.
So in effect, they would
take innovation leadership,
innovate in the
production system
process and technologies, and
be able to compete better.
That's the essential question.
And as I mentioned last
week, MIT for example,
there are 14
manufacturing institutes
that have been stood up
in the last few years.
MIT is participating
in 9 of the 14,
leading one particularly
active and about three or four
but also participant
in the others.
So this is something
that's now ongoing
on this campus in a
pretty sizable way.
So that's the background
on manufacturing.
Now we go back to
our whole project
on innovation organization.
That's today's class.
And we're looking
at that problem
of how do you innovate at
the institutional level?
And in particular, we're looking
at where did the US innovation
system come from?
How did it get created?
How did it get put together?
And that's the story
that we'll weave today.
As a backdrop to that,
we'll start with a framework
that a scholar named
David Hart put together.
David teaches at George
Mason University.
He teaches innovation
policy issues there.
And he wrote this-- he got
his PhD from MIT and STS.
He was head service in
the Office of Science
and Technology Policy
so he as practical
as well as a lot of
academic experience.
Authored a big book on
energy innovation policy.
David did this
book back in 1998,
and he essentially argued that
what's the ideology of science
and technology policy?
If you put it into a political
economy kind of context,
what is the thinking process?
How do you think about this?
And he identified kind
of five political strains
in the US that, frankly--
you know, I worked in the
Senate for over 15 years.
I saw them all.
They were real.
They were all still there.
There were all ways of
thinking about science and tech
policy, R&D policy that
I saw all the time.
So these are very
much alive and well.
And David tried to put
a frame around them,
and they will help guide us on
the politics of science support
and technology support
in this country.
So what are these five visions?
I'm going to summarize
them briefly.
And which of our discussion
leaders has David Hart?
Chloe.
OK.
So the first was conservatism.
Now, this perspective saw
no need for the state,
for the federal government,
to do anything other
than providing for
defense, including
military technological
innovation.
Get the state out
of everything else.
They've got to do defense,
but leave the rest
to the private sector.
It's a very
non-interventionist philosophy.
The budget that President
Trump just sent to Capitol Hill
for FY '18, largely written
by the Heritage Foundation,
argues exactly this
theoretical line.
It takes-- it eliminates
ARPA-E. It takes $2 billion
out of the Applied
Research Agencies
and takes almost $1 billion out
of the basic research agencies
at DOD.
It's a gigantic cutback.
The theory is, let the
private sector do it.
They'll do this energy stuff.
So this is right on us.
This theoretical framework
for approaching R&D support
is right there.
One of its leading
proponents, and we'll
run into him when we
talk about Alfred Loomis,
one of its leading proponents
in this period that David
is writing about in
the '20s and '30s
when these ideologies really got
put together, was Frank Jewett.
Jewett was head of Bell Labs.
And he was president of
the National Academies.
Had both slots.
And he's head of Bell Labs.
He's got one of the
great basic research
as well as applied
research organizations
in the history of the world.
There is a phone monopoly.
The last thing he wants
is the federal government
messing around in his turf.
Naturally, he's a proponent
of keeping the feds out,
except in defense and military,
which they've got to do.
So we'll run into to Frank
Jewett in a few minutes.
But this is a noninterventionist
defense-only piece.
Now, on the other
side of that argument
is what David calls
associationalism.
We would call this
public-private partnership.
That's the lingo that's more
or less used at this time.
But the meaning is
roughly the same.
David points out that the
first big exponent of this
was Herbert Hoover, who
along with Jimmy Carter,
was one of the
only two engineers
to ever be president
of the United States.
That doesn't mean there can't
be more, just as a lesson to you
all.
Hoover was an amazing engineer.
He was a great organizer of the
World War I war relief effort
to save a staggering number
of lives after World War I.
He was a highly innovative
Secretary of Commerce
and made that at
the time actually
one of the most important
Cabinet agencies.
His vision was that unlimited
economic competition
curtails firms' ability
to be innovative.
If you're frantic
about your competitors,
you're not going to have the
energy, time, or resources
to spend on longer-term,
higher-risk R&D.
So there ought to be a gathering
between public and private
sectors that would
collaboratively undertake this.
So this associationalism
really occurs in the 1920s.
He is a great leader of NIST,
the standards organization.
That would be a classic
public-private collaboration,
where private industry
under government auspices
would come together
and negotiate and work
on standards for products
to enable their much more
efficient production.
So that would be a classic
Hoover kind of effort.
Franklin Roosevelt adopts
this associationalist attitude
when he becomes president.
There's a lot of
public-private connectivity
during the Roosevelt regime.
So that gives us two models.
Now, this next model,
it's kind of disappeared.
But it was a big
movement in the 1930s.
The basic theory was
that cartels, monopolies,
collusion amongst firms
discouraged innovation.
You build up market control.
The last thing you want
is a disruptive product.
And we can see this, of
course, in a sector like energy
even now.
So the concept was reestablish
markets by legislation
or through example by
anti-trust laws or regulation,
and you would
encourage innovation
to break out, because you'd be
breaking up the cartels that
were limiting innovation.
There's so much global
competition now,
and the competition is so
intense that, frankly, there's
just not that much going on in
anti-trust practice or theory.
Firms may be curtailing
innovation because
of day-to-day
competitive pressures,
but that's not an
underlying cartel problem,
because the
competition is there.
So this one is less present
now than it was back
in that kind of '30s timetable.
A fourth is keynesianism.
You remember John
Maynard Keynes.
Keynes develops some
crucial fundamentals
of economic theory.
His principle contribution
is that in periods
of economic downturn,
government spending
can step up to the
plate and substitute
for the decline in private
spending and, in effect,
stabilize an economy.
So we just saw this
whole theory played out
in the Economic Stimulus Bill.
That's what happened in
the 2009 Stimulus Bill.
Massive economic stimulus.
I think the economists
would say that it worked.
It did stabilize the economy
in fairly surprisingly
short order, given the
depth of the threat.
We didn't slip into another
great recession or Great
Depression.
But the idea here, as applies
to science and technology,
is look out for the
macro-investment levels.
Have a governmental role in
funding investment in research
and development, because
the public sector is not
prone to take longer-term risks.
And the government can
substitute for that.
So this factor is still with us.
That's why in the
first class when
I had you read the National
Science Foundation Indicators
that told us all about
investment levels
by government in R&D,
that's Keynesian thinking.
That's government substituting
because the private sector has
difficulty undertaking
longer-term high-risk
investment in research.
So that's another ideological
kind of element here.
The fifth is a little
bit like conservatism,
but it's much more far-reaching.
This emerges in World
War II and the Cold War.
And this doctrine says,
whatever it takes.
National security is so
critical, we will do anything.
The government will be
every bit as interventionist
as it needs to be in order
to get us national security.
And that's still
very much alive.
I'd say someone like Senator
John McCain, who is currently
the Chairman of the
Armed Services Committee,
Senator McCain is probably
a conservative when it comes
to federal R&D investment,
generally speaking,
but when it comes to
defense, whatever it takes.
So an organization like
In-Q-Tel, which essentially
buys a controlling
share in companies so
that the government can get
the technologies at once,
it's government becoming a
venture capitalist on steroids.
McCain is a huge
fan of that model.
And In-Q-Tel works in
the intelligence security
kind of area.
So this movement is around too.
And this is essentially what
Vannevar Bush puts together
when he creates a
connected science model--
we'll talk about
it a little later--
during World War II.
So these are the ideologies.
I'll just summarize
them very quickly again.
Conservatism.
Government can do military
innovation, but that's it.
Associationlism.
That's the public-private
partnership model.
Reform liberalism, which
is stamp out cartels.
They limit innovation.
And that's not really
a powerful movement
at this point because of
international competition.
Keynesianism, which is
analyze science and technology
based upon these
macro-investment levels
by the public
sector, which serves
to offset a market failure
on the private sector side.
And then the fifth one is
this national security state.
So when I was working
in the Senate,
I saw all of these,
sometimes all them
in a single day in debate
on the Senate floor,
as people would take
different perspectives
and different political
understandings
of the role of R&D in
science and technology.
So these are all still
very much with us
and guide a lot of
thinking to this day.
The latest example,
as I mentioned,
was President Trump's
FY '18 budget,
and it's his position--
explicit position--
on supporting research, which
a lot of it the private sector
could just pick up.
It's just straight out of
the conservatism playbook.
CHLOE: All right.
Chloe, it's yours.
OK.
So first of all, obviously
he gave a rundown--
very effective rundown--
of all the different--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You
didn't have to say that.
CHLOE: Just curious
why I wouldn't do that
for a third time
and for everyone.
I think just in conclusion,
tagging onto that,
it's interesting to note, and
Hart sort of makes the point,
that an ever-changing
political tide--
he says that it generates a
lot of policy entrepreneurs.
So people coming out
and being like, oh, this
is my new policy.
It's brand new.
It's never been seen before.
But in actuality, a lot of
these theories were Frankenstein
models from previous theories,
and the successful ones often
owed their success in part
to the pre-existence of other
institutions that they could--
and resources that
already existed
that they could
repurpose for readjusting
their mission for
how they viewed
how science and technology
research funding
should actually go about.
So in looking through a lot of
your summaries and questions,
it seemed like a
lot of people wanted
to discuss the relevance
of these five visions
to this particular time period,
maybe what political climate we
have now, like what combination,
what hybrid of these five
that we are living with today,
and then also maybe what
components of each are
actually successful,
in your own personal
opinion or experience,
for funding research.
So just to sort of hone in on--
I found associationalism
and liberal--
reform liberalism the two
most interesting ones.
This is my first
question for you
all, sort of talk about a bit
of a tragedy of the commons type
situation.
So the institutions
desired by associationalism
are intriguing.
But does such an
implementation have a degree
of naivete outside of wartime?
Are all who utilized new
information as a resource--
do all who utilize the
information as a resource
as an end to the mean
of their final product,
are they also invested
in the idea of sharing
that information with
their competition,
even on a national scale?
I think that's something a
lot of people would think
is naive perspective.
MAX: Well, it probably
depends on the context.
So if you were to look at
Conant actually-- yeah,
shameless plug, because
that's my reading--
so if you look at that, in the
time period in World War II,
you had companies that were
fighting this absolute evil
that was going to just
engulf the entire planet
in a Nazi regime.
So people were scared.
So they thought,
OK, you know what?
We're going to do whatever
it takes to fight this.
And it was in
everyone's best interest
to fight it and share all the
knowledge that they could.
Actually, in another class,
I was reading a case study
on-- your part of
Lincoln Electric.
It's this company,
they make arc welders.
They've been working
for a few decades,
and they actually shared a lot
of their manufacturing secrets
during World War II,
just for that reason.
So that's one way that it's not
extremely naive, like they just
need the right incentive.
On the other hand, if
you look at today when
there isn't an overarching
evil that everyone
can unite behind and try to
fight against, people have--
they don't have
as much incentive
to share all their secrets.
CHLOE: So you think
that you specifically
need that defense urge for
that cooperation to exist.
MAX: That's what
history has shown me,
at least from what I can tell.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
I'm glad to tell you,
Max, that next week we'll have
a reading that's entitled,
is war necessary
for economic growth?
So we will continue
this discussion-- that's
week two-- in addition to that.
CHLOE: Do you think that
any institution that
might benefit from this sort
of like government-funded
encyclopedia of information, do
you think people wouldn't want
to contribute to that or
take from that in a time
where there wasn't this
pre-existing military need?
Because I mean, I think it's
arguable that you would still
benefit-- a lot of
these theories, to me,
one of the overarching things I
noticed is that a lot of them--
a lot of people seem
to feel the need
for the government providing
something that would facilitate
communication between
innovators and people
who implemented
them in industry.
It would save a lot of time if
the people who-- if everyone
had the same terms
and everyone knew what
was possible and achievable.
And I don't know if that's
something that implementable,
even outside of a time
when the country all
needs to work together.
MAX: It also could--
it could scare some
people who went
through the Great Recession,
where you've got industries
that are quote, unquote,
"too big to fail,"
because then if you have all
these industries that are all
sharing all of
their information,
then in some sense, they
kind of are becoming
one big conglomerate then.
At least, that's the way
that the thinking could go.
Now, there are flaws
with that, like they
don't share the same
finances, the same employees,
all sorts of stuff.
But people could rationalize
that it's a step toward that.
And from there, that also
could reduce competition.
Then you have, hey, the
anti-trust laws come back,
and they're actually
interesting again.
CHLOE: I think
that's a good point.
MAX: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So Chloe, you're
pushing us to the point
that, given your interest in
the associationalist, model,
the public-private
partnership model,
this is exactly what
Hoover was driving at,
that there may be
a way of creating
at least limited
cooperation, particularly
around fundamentals,
what has become known
as pre-competitive research.
In other words,
research before it
reaches a competitive level
that's key to your company.
At least you could all cooperate
on the pre-competitive stuff.
So that has been a conscious
part of the design of some
of these public-private
partnership models
in timetables like the
Clinton administration,
for example in particular.
Could companies come
together and share resources
around this
pre-competitive stuff,
even if they were going to
be at each other's throats
the moment that
work was completed?
And how practical is that?
Are they really going to
be willing to do that?
So the manufacturing institutes
that we mentioned last week,
this is a critical
issue for them,
absolutely critical issue.
How do you get all these
manufacturing companies,
small and large,
into the same room
to cooperate when they're
all also in competition
and the Manufacturing
Institute model is actually
pretty applied stuff.
It's around production processes
that for some companies
may be their secret sauce.
So how do you--
you've identified a
really critical barrier
in this associationalist model.
How do you get this
kind of collaboration,
given the reality and
importance of competition?
MARTHA: I'll come
in [INAUDIBLE]..
I've been here for a while.
I'll throw in a thought,
though, of course,
which is I do think it's
really specific areas
and pre-competitive and then
also enabling technologies,
like looking today, and we're
not seeing it really happen,
but at the MIT
Energy Initiative,
companies are excited--
energy companies are excited
about getting together
on carbon capture
and sequestration,
partly to enable them to just
keep running their companies.
Now, we haven't seen anything
formal really happen,
and the technology is still
way too expensive, et cetera.
But I think in specific
areas that it can happen.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
It's an interesting
idea, Martha.
In other words,
in areas that are
outside your core
competitive advantage,
could you get
together with others,
because it might help everybody?
Right?
MARTHA: And I was wondering that
about the Manufacturing Bill.
I am not that
knowledgeable about it,
but if you consider
your secret sauce is
something other than the
actual manufacturing,
if you're a conglomerate that
has great product design,
you know, I don't
know, does that work?
I don't know.
I don't know where you
were willing to open up
your secrets to others.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
One of the
manufacturing institutes
we talked about last week
was around 3D printing.
And it turns out
that that is going
to be an absolutely
critical core
technology and the way in which
anybody ever makes another jet
aircraft engine.
I mean, maybe not this
week, but certainly
in the foreseeable future.
It's going to be
absolutely critical.
So there's frankly been
a tremendous amount
of nervousness when
companies like Pratt and GE
and Lockheed and Boeing and
others come into the same room
and who's ahead?
And are they going to
share their secret sauce?
And how is this going to work?
So working on the intellectual
property agreements
has been really complicated.
So this public-private
partnership model,
there's a lot of examples
of it working brilliantly,
but it is not an
easy model to bring
these highly-competitive
firms together and try
to get them to
agree on an agenda
that they might be able to work
together on that would save
them all resources and funding.
And Martha runs into that,
I'm sure, every day in MITii.
MARTHA: And we will more and
more with these consortia
that we're putting together.
CHLOE: I thought another--
to bring free-form liberalism
into the discussion-- an
interesting contrast that
emerged between them, sort of
off of that topic of trying
to figure out who
the other people--
like, what they're thinking--
other people in the room,
what they're thinking, and what
your competition is thinking,
is that both these two policies
seem to have very different--
two theories-- seem to have
very different views on--
to get a philosophical--
the innate
goodness or lack thereof
in industry leaders.
And I think this was such fun.
I forget the name
of the reading.
It was a later one
about how there's
a philosophical difference
between basic research
and applied research
and the people who
make a career out of each.
At the end of the day, they
have different end goals
and different core values.
So I thought it was
interesting that that
was sort of superimposed
onto industry leaders,
and I wasn't quite
sure if that actually
makes a wide base for
an economic policy,
is judgment calls
about human nature.
So I know that's a
little touchy-feely,
but I'd be interested to hear
if anyone was like, good idea,
bad idea.
AUDIENCE: I have the reading
that you're talking about.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Stokes, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I think a really
important distinction that he
makes is that whether to sort of
base it off like a speculating,
like speculating if these
are the goals of the actors
or like retroactively knowing.
And I think that's a really
important distinction,
because if you're making
policy, of course, you can't--
hindsight is 20/20,
but you're not
going to know retroactively.
But you have to have some
degree of speculation, which
is something that I think--
well, I wasn't quite sure what
Stokes was trying to say there,
but he was saying
that the retroactive
way of looking at it is
actually better than speculating
when looking at it.
But I think it's a
little bit impractical
when you're thinking
about policy decisions
to kind of try to interpret what
the goals of the certain actor
are going to be based on
something like human nature
or like some other type of kind
of non-tangible measurement.
CHLOE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Chloe, would you
give us a closing
thought on David Hart?
CHLOE: Sure.
I guess, would a
closing question be OK?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Sure.
CHLOE: Because still I haven't--
this is a central question
for me, one that I haven't--
I feel like we haven't
come to a conclusion on.
How have these policies sort
of survived the test of time,
because they're all
so built on each other
and come from different
periods, World War II, Cold
War, the Korean War, and
different manufacturing stages
throughout our history?
They're all sort of
interwoven and interdependent.
What does that
leave us with today?
What lessons have we
learned and what theories
are working for us right now?
Yeah.
STEPH: I thought that
an interesting concern
about the Hart reading was
that it sort of presumed
that scientists and
technologists were not
a part of the policymaking
process, that they're
sort of receivers of the
actions of policymakers.
So I thought it would
be interesting to think
about maybe today or in the
next election cycle for midterms
and congressional elections,
what it would look
like if there were
more scientists
and technologists
running for Congress
and as policymakers and
maybe a scientist running
for president someday or
a technologist running
for president, as
they have speculated
Mark Zuckerberg to be doing.
Because in that sense,
it wouldn't so much
be a conflict
between ideologies,
but a conflict between
how much that person chose
to put in money in the
industry that they're a part of
and how much they are
motivated by what they know
and what they don't know.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You
put your finger right
on a pulse of a
critical issue, Steph.
The reason why I'm teaching
this class is so that all of you
will be citizen
scientists and be
ready to do great science and
engineering and technology
and run venture capital
firms and start companies.
I want you to do all that
stuff, but in addition,
if you would also hold public
office, I'd appreciate it too.
No, in other words,
the science-- this
is an intensely
interest-group-driven
political system we've got.
And if you don't show up,
you don't get counted.
And frankly, science
and engineering
doesn't show up very much.
And there's a lot at
stake, as we speak, now.
And part of the story is that
the community of scientists
and engineers, they're
not on the front lines.
And in an
interest-driven society,
that's really problematic.
Now, it's storytelling time.
I couldn't resist putting this
in, because at least those
of you from MIT, this is an
important part of your history.
But I think it's
fun for everybody.
This is Alfred Loomis and Luis
Alvarez, the great physicist,
called him the last of the
great amateurs of science.
And you know, he's a
very good-looking guy,
as you can tell.
That's the Rad Lab in MIT,
where the Stata Building is now.
That's Rad Lab
latest radar sets.
This is an early army radar set.
And that's the business of the
Rad Lab that Loomis creates.
And what's this story?
So if you go over to Stata
and you wander around
on the first floor, at the end
of one of the student streets,
you're going to see some
of these radar sets.
And there's plaques and
stuff around there saying
this was where the Rad Lab was.
And from an MIT perspective,
one statistic you need to know
is that in the period from 1941
to 1945, MIT as an institution
received 80 times more
federal funding than it did
in all its previous 80 years.
This is what creates the
federally funded research
university.
And it starts big
time at the Rad Lab.
This is where MIT becomes a
critical and big and important
institution.
It really scales up.
It's not alone.
This is happening at other
research universities
across the country.
And it's the story of Loomis.
So let me just give you a
little background on him.
Born in 1887, died in 1975.
He comes from this WASP
blue-blood family in New York.
And his father is
a society doctor,
serving those blue bloods.
I'm not sure they ever
had any health problems.
But if they did, his
father was there.
Until his father runs
off with his secretary.
This is when Loomis's
life changes.
Loomis is now stuck with the
responsibility for the family.
He can't do what he wanted
to do, study science.
Instead, he has to go to
become an investment banker,
heaven forbid.
So he has technical
training and a love
for science and strong
undergraduate science training.
He goes into investment banking.
He understands technology.
He makes an absolute, one of
the great fortunes of the 1920s,
and his investment
banking firm is setting up
utility companies,
utility holding companies.
He understands the electricity
technology, the transmission
technology.
He's able to capitalize
on that and make
a fortune for
essentially electrifying
large parts of the country.
He sees what's going to happen.
And in 1928, he takes his
entire fortune, every last dime
and gets out of the market,
because he saw the bubble.
And then what's he do?
So he's got the estate, Tudor
house, pond, grounds, lawns,
40 acres' worth in a
place called Tuxedo Park,
which is about 40 miles
north of New York City.
The tuxedo, you know,
the funny penguin suit,
comes from Tuxedo Park.
That's the kind of
clothing they used
to wear there in the evening.
Gives you an idea
of what it's like.
It's like the first kind
of gated multi-acre suburb
for this compound for
staggeringly rich people
from New York City, only
40 miles north of the city.
So he's got this
Tudor mansion there.
He loves science.
He's walked out with his
entire fortune intact.
He creates probably the top
private research laboratory
in the 1930s.
And he staffs it with an
incredible group of scientists.
But in particular, he
specializes in what we now
call the summer study.
And he's there
researching himself.
His field is physics,
particularly microwave physics.
And he invites in the
who's who of physics
from all over the world.
So the famous
European physicists
are there for summer projects,
and they're rowing on the pond
and playing lawn tennis
on his lawn tennis courts,
and doing little
research, and talking away
and having great meals.
It's a nice setting.
All right.
You get the picture.
He gets to know the whole
who's who of physics,
and he's doing important
work himself in physics,
in this microwave physics area.
Time passes.
World War II breaks
out in Europe.
He's very sympathetic
to the Brits.
His mentor, his first
cousin, is Henry Stimson,
who's Secretary of War to
Franklin Roosevelt. Stimson's
a famous leader of the War
Department during World War II
and a very talented, highly
respected figure in that era.
He had been Secretary of State
previously in the Coolidge
administration.
Stimson trusts Loomis.
They're first cousins,
but in effect, Stimson
is Loomis's father figure.
So Loomis becomes a very
critical advisor to Stimson
in this pre-war
period of '39 and '40.
And in addition, Loomis is
serving with Vannevar Bush, who
we'll talk about in a minute,
on the early defense research
committees.
So let's switch to Britain.
So Britain and the United
States develop radar roughly
about the same time.
In the US context, it
was developed by the Navy
at the Naval Research Laboratory
on the Anacostia River.
And they were fiddling
around with radio,
and they were
shooting radio beams
across the Anacostia River.
And they noticed
this peculiar thing,
which was a boat would
come down the river
and the radio beam
would bounce back.
Voila.
Radar.
The British were
doing experiments
at roughly the same time period.
And because the US wasn't 100
miles away from German bombers
or 200 miles away
from German bombers,
there was no sense of
emergency in developing
radar in the United States.
There was a considerable
sense of emergency developing
radar in Germany.
The going doctrine
of the time, based
upon what happened
in Spanish Civil War,
was that mass bombing
was going to be
a core offensive
military strategy
and that there was
nothing you could
do to stop the bombers
from getting through.
The bomber will
always get through
was the prevailing doctrine.
And people began to see
the effect of mass bombing
from sites like Guernica
during the Spanish Civil War.
And it was a nightmare.
It was a complete nightmare.
It dictated a lot of the
politics of appeasement
in the 1930s, because
the assumption
was that you couldn't defend
against these bombing raids
and that cities like
London and others
would just be leveled
at huge slaughter.
So if your assumption is
that you can't defend it
against them, that
you're going to lose,
and that you're going to lose
a huge part of your population,
you can understand where a
lot of appeasement doctrine
comes from, where Chamberlain
and Baldwin are coming from.
Meanwhile, Winston
Churchill, always a maverick,
is trying to figure out what
to do about the situation,
because it's untenable from
his political perspective.
So there's an
interesting figure named
Tizard, who is head of
Imperial College in London,
previously a professor.
But in World War I a
pilot and in World War I,
because his eyes
weren't that good,
he was relegated to
being a test pilot
in the RAF, the early
version of the Royal Air
Force, Royal Flying Corps.
And he learned pilot talk and
how to get along with pilots.
He was one, and he
knows the language,
and he understands how it works.
And the radar idea
comes to Tizard.
As a noted academic,
he's heading
a scientific advisory group
for the Royal Air Force.
And he seizes on
and realizes this
could be the core of
a defensive strategy
against the bomber, that
might be able to stop it
from going through.
And just because you
have a technology idea,
it doesn't mean anybody in the
military is going to adopt it.
It's got to become operational.
So he spends years working
with the Royal Air Force trying
to develop an operational
doctrine to integrate
these early long-range radar
systems, the communications
with the Spitfires and fighter
planes and the Hurricanes,
to communicate the results
that they're seeing
on their long-range
radar screens,
get those up to the fighter
pilots, get them up in the air
and get them to the right
location at the right time.
That's critical, because you
can't maintain continuous cover
with fighter planes.
They're short distance,
and they're under-fueled,
and they have limited range.
So if you try to defend
against 1,000 bombers,
you can only have a certain
number of fighter planes
up in the air at
any given moment.
But if you know exactly when
the bombers are coming in
and exactly where
they're going to be
and what altitude
they're going to be at,
then you can mash
your fighter planes
and get them position ahead
of time and then take them on.
And that's what the British
figured out with radar.
Now, their system
was long-wave radar.
So they had like a system
all around the coast
of like these big 60-foot
telephone pole kinds of things.
And then these
big 30-foot things
that looked like
bed springs, only
they were about 30 feet long.
And it was called the
Chain Home System.
It was all around the
critical parts of the coast.
And then they would get
information from the radar sets
to an operational center
that would run the fighter
plane cover system at air bases
throughout the British Isles
and scramble these jets--
scramble these fighter
planes and get them up just
in the nick of time.
It's very clumsy, because the
pilots don't have the radar.
They're talking to somebody who
is in turn talking to somebody
about what the radar says.
You can imagine what the
communication is like.
I mean, you have to get it down
to almost a separate language
on how to communicate to people.
So it's very tough.
Wouldn't it be better if the
radar was in the airplane?
But if it's
long-wave, how are you
going to put this 30-foot bed
spring into a fighter aircraft?
That's the problem.
So the British work on--
frantically working
on microwave radar.
You know, 10-centimeter long
radar beams with the idea
that whoever figures
this out is going
to have a staggering tactical
and strategic advantage
in the war.
And they put a team on
it, and they come up
with 12 early sets
of microwave radar.
Then what are they going to do?
Well, Britain has so
allowed its industrial base
to erode that the best thinking
is we're going flat-out
on building munitions,
we don't have capacity
to take up this whole new
territory of effectively invent
electronics.
We can't do that.
Who could do it?
The Americans.
So Churchill, pressed
by to Tizard and others,
comes up with the
idea that they'll
take microwave radar and
a bunch of other secrets
that they've got, because
remember, British science is
very strong, probably
stronger than American science
at this point.
We wouldn't think so, but
that's probably the case.
And Tizard is nominated to lead
a mission to the United States
and essentially offer to put--
they offer to put their
secrets on the table
if we, the United States, will
put our secrets on the table.
We'll trade secrets.
That would be the deal.
So a group of scientists and
a couple of military officers
get on a high-speed
passenger ship.
Now, passenger ships are
moving at about 30 knots
across the ocean.
U-boats are much slower.
On the surface, 14, 15 knots.
Far slower if they're
running below the surface.
So nobody sank a passenger
ship on the Atlantic route
during World War II.
They always got across.
So they go into Halifax,
and they have in a suitcase
the most critical
secret of the war,
one of these 12
microwave radar sets.
Loomis flies over to Halifax.
They take the train down.
They go to Washington.
There's a meeting at
the Wardman Park Hotel.
At the Wardman Park--
I bet you it's still there--
Loomis, rich guy,
consulting in Washington,
trying to help the
war effort, he's
got a penthouse on the top
of the Wardman Park Hotel.
Fireplace.
I'm sure it's nice.
The meeting is at a private
dining room downstairs,
just off the big dining room at
this fancy Wardman Park Hotel.
Loomis, as Stimson's
unofficial advisor
about science and
technology, has
convened the military
leaders from the services,
from the Army and Marine
Corps and the Air Force,
and this is apocryphal.
It may not exactly be
the case, but in essence,
our uniformed
military leaders have
decided that they're not going
to agree to exchange secrets.
They're not going to do it.
They think Britain
is going down.
Battle of Britain is
hanging in the balance.
They think Britain
is going to lose.
Anything that goes
to Britain is going
to fall in the hands of Germany.
So they hit on a strategy,
is the apocryphal part,
of pretending to get
drunk at the meal
and falling asleep
in their soup dishes.
This may be exaggerated.
It was told to me by
someone, but we'll see.
So they do it, and
the Brits have just
come across the ocean.
They've got the suitcase
with them in the room.
I mean, you know, the war
is hanging in the balance.
The war could be one
if these yanks just
pick up this technology
and manufacture it.
Lots at stake.
And they start throwing
out hints, little hints
about this cavity
magnetron, as they call it,
and it's microwave capabilities.
And of course, sitting
at the head of the table
as Alfred Loomis, who happens to
be America's leading microwave
physicist at this point,
author of numerous articles
and so forth.
No PhD, but for every
intent and purpose,
the leading scientist
in the field.
He gets the hints.
He's been working on a much
earlier stage of radar himself.
He starts to understand
what they're talking about.
Little more time
passes, Loomis goes up
to his penthouse with
Tizard and the five others,
sitting around the fireplace,
and the story comes out.
And then they in
turn meet at, you
guessed it, Tuxedo Park and
the suitcase exchanges hands.
And then Loomis, who probably
unique in the country,
is capable of understanding
what this technology is,
how powerful it is.
If you put a radar set in an
airplane, the airplane can see.
The airplane can fly at night,
not just during the daytime.
It can do its own interception
and its own targeting.
It doesn't have to rely on
clumsy radar signals going
through two or three
people down on the ground.
It's a transformative
technology.
He understands what it is.
He's been himself working
on kind of a much earlier
stage of this.
What's he do?
Well, never underestimate the
power of WASP blue blood family
connections.
So he immediately
gets on the phone
with Henry Stimson, his
first cousin and mentor
and surrogate father.
Henry, got to move on this.
Go see Roosevelt.
Henry, same day, goes to see
Franklin Roosevelt. Franklin
Roosevelt, the Dutch WASP
blue blood family connections,
yes, move on it, Henry.
So literally within a day, the
fundamental decisions are made.
Tizard advises Loomis on the
structure of the organization
that the Brits have put
together to do this.
And the Americans decide
to do the same thing.
So what did Tizard set up?
This is not a bureaucratic
military laboratory
that is doing radar in Britain.
This is civilian scientists,
not in uniform, organized
in a loose almost academic kind
of flat, non-hierarchical way,
where everybody pitches
in with the best ideas.
There's leadership,
there's organization,
but it's not a
military bureaucracy.
Loomis doesn't have to
be persuaded of this.
He had worked in the war
effort in World War I
and found the military
bureaucracy impregnable
to ideas.
It had been completely
frustrating to him.
Vannevar Bush had a similar
experience, complete frustrated
as well.
So they latch onto the way in
which the Brits have organized
their scientific advisory
groups and their organizational
efforts for doing science
in a wartime setting.
The microwave radar is a
really important importation.
The model of
scientific organization
is every bit as important.
And Loomis runs with them both.
Loomis immediately
gets hold of one
of his very best friends,
who is Ernest Lawrence, who
is the most prominent American
physicist at the time.
Loomis had been personally
funding Ernest Lawrence's work
to build the early cyclotrons
up on Cyclotron Road
up above the Berkeley campus,
where Lawrence is a professor.
They're very close.
Loomis has been paying
for him and his projects.
So he gets Lawrence on the
phone and says get out here.
I can't talk to
you on the phone.
Let's get out of here.
Lawrence-- it's
unusual at the time--
he doesn't take the
train, he flies,
meets within days with Loomis.
The two of them
get on the phone.
Because of the summer
studies at Tuxedo Park,
Loomis knows everybody and
Lawrence knows everybody else.
They get on the phone, and the
conversations are like this--
hi.
We're going to set
up a new laboratory.
We can't tell you
anything about it.
Arrive in Cambridge in two
weeks and quit your job.
They all come.
So powerful are Loomis and
Lawrence that they come.
The who's who of physics in
the United States shows up.
Now, why are they going
to show up in Cambridge?
It's another critical
part of our story.
Here's some of the characters
that were in the room.
So there's this defense advisory
group that Vannevar Bush, here,
is running.
And Loomis is his advisor,
here, on air defense microwave
radar, all this radar stuff.
And Vannevar Bush and
Loomis call a meeting
to make a decision
about where to put
this new Critical Defense
Laboratory that's going
to work on microwave radar.
Not in this picture is--
you remember Frank Jewett,
the exponent of conservatism
who is head of Bell Labs
and the National Academies?
Frank is in the room.
Frank says, well, we're
going to put it at Bell Labs.
It's where it's going to go.
Who would even think otherwise?
There's a vote.
So in the room is Karl Compton,
president at MIT, and James
Conant, president of Harvard.
You may recall that those
two schools are in Cambridge.
Loomis and Vannevar Bush, and
that's Lawrence, by the way.
And that's Arthur Compton,
who is Karl's brother, also
a quite prominent and
important physicist at the time
and involved in
this defense work.
But he's not in the room.
And then Jewett.
So it's one, two, three,
four, plus Frank Jewett.
Surprise.
The vote is 4 to 1.
It's going to go to MIT.
And all there is at
MIT is industrial space
all over the place.
And it's just coming
out of the depression.
So there's a lot
of space in MIT.
So President Compton
volunteers the space.
And that's how come the Rad
Lab gets stood up at MIT.
And it is a remarkably
successful organization.
This is how-- this is the
foundation of electronics
in the United States.
This is where most
of that comes from.
Of the numerous scientists
that worked at the Rad Lab,
I think 10 win the Nobel Prize.
The group of scientists that
set up the Rad Lab do it on this
radical, flat,
non-hierarchical, collaborative
stay-out-of-uniform
organizational model.
Loomis plays a critical
role in scaling up
the Manhattan Project, which
had been kind of desultory.
So Loomis next jumps
on that problem
and gets that organized.
Oppenheimer, who we will
talk about in class 7,
is designated to
head that project.
Oppenheimer doesn't know
how to organize this stuff.
Eleven people go from the Rad
Lab to organize Los Alamos
and work there.
And II Rabi, who is from the Rad
Lab, a great Columbia physicist
and Nobel Prize winner, he
becomes Oppenheimer's advisor
on how to organize the
Los Alamos project.
So you begin to get
the picture here.
It's a great story about
a particular technology,
but frankly, more
important than that story
is a story of
scientific organization.
How are we going to organize
science in this country?
And what we call the FFRDC,
Federally Funded Research
and Development Center, that
is going to be the model.
And the first one of those
is the Rad Lab at MIT.
Then Los Alamos and then so on.
Lincoln Laboratory
up the street is
organized on exactly
these same kind of lines.
So it's the organizational
model in the end
that's most critical.
Rasheed.
RASHEED: This is a point--
I'm pretty sure that's
a cyclotron drawing
on the chalkboard
in the picture?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's very cool.
I've always wondered
what it was.
RASHEED: Yeah.
You can tell by the two halves
of the circle on the right.
Yeah.
And then I'm pretty sure that's
a magnet drawing in the middle
there on the left.
I don't know what's
going on above it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This one?
RASHEED: Yeah.
Random sinusoid.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Thank you.
That's great.
Now I know the picture better.
If you could check that out,
that would be fascinating.
RASHEED: Yeah.
I mean, if Ernest Lawrence drew
it, it's probably a cyclotron.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I don't see the chalk
in his hand, though.
I don't know.
But it's entirely possible.
But I think they're all smiling
and happy because they just
rolled Bell Labs
and Frank Jewett,
I think is what's going on.
All right.
That's my storytelling.
RASHEED: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: What's that?
STEPH: Oh, I looked
up the blueprint.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
It is a cyclotron.
RASHEED: Cool.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Is it?
Steph, it's a cyclotron?
Great.
Rasheed, good.
That was good.
STEPH: Created by UC Berkeley.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Hey, that's Lawrence.
This guy.
MAX: I had no idea
that Karl Compton was
both the guy who made Compton
scattering and the president
of MIT.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh, yeah.
MAX: I didn't-- awesome.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
This is an unbelievable
collection in this room.
That is hard to beat that
collection of talent.
And Janet Conant's
grandfather is James Conant.
So she's able to do
the book on Loomis,
because she's got all
the family records, all
the correspondence.
So Rasheed, we have a
scientific consensus
that that's what it is?
RASHEED: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
Great.
Thank you.
That will add a whole new
piece to the evolution
of the story over time.
STEPH: It's what social
scientists are good for.
We do research.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's good.
All right.
Max, have you got this one?
MAX: Yep.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
MAX: All right.
So--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You could actually
tell us what actually happened.
MAX: Yeah.
Let's see.
I don't know.
You covered it in spades.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's one
of my favorite story tellings.
MAX: Yeah, I gathered.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: One
story time in most classes.
MAX: I did appreciate--
so something
I gather when I
was reading it, I
thought this had taken
place before the Manhattan
Project was ever formed.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh, yes.
Absolutely right.
MAX: OK, which I thought--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So this group
may well be gathering around
next stages of the Manhattan
Project.
MAX: Yeah.
OK.
So--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Because these folks
are central to everything
that goes on in science
in that World War II period.
MAX: So I thought that
was one of the general,
like that emphasized the
genius of this group,
because before then,
there weren't really like
giant gatherings of this sort.
And it was before the
Manhattan Project.
So something of that scale
had never been done before.
LUYAN: What is the
Manhattan Project?
MAX: What?
LUYAN: What is the
Manhattan Project?
MAX: Oh, to build
the atomic bomb.
Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So Luyan, that's
the great crash project at
Los Alamos up on a mason
surrounded by barbed wire,
way off in the deserts
of New Mexico that does
most of the critical work
on developing atomic weapons
in the course of World War II.
And the great fear, as
Max suggested earlier,
was that most of US physicists
knew Heisenberg personally.
And Heisenberg's in charge of
the German atomic projects.
They know how brilliant he is.
They think he's going
to get there first,
that they're way behind.
And the war would
be over in an hour
if Germany had
gotten there first.
So that's why there's such a
crash project to put together
the Manhattan Project.
But this Rad Lab
stuff is equally
important from a
tactical point of view,
in terms of the ability
of aircraft to operate,
the power of air power in World
War II, the ability of radar
systems to see
incoming airstrikes,
the ability of fleets
to manage air attacks.
All that stuff
comes out of here,
and those are critical
day-to-day developments
in World War II.
So the atomic bomb may have been
the final ending of the war,
but the day-to-day
warfare is dramatically
changed by the microwave radar.
MAX: So the first
question that I
thought of when I was just
looking at all this reading,
I was thinking, well, they
were able to take this design
and build up the manufacturing
facilities, build up the labs,
scale everything,
get all the people,
and make these planes
with this radar equipment
really quickly, because the
war is only like four years.
So they had to do all of
that in that time span.
So what struck me was just how
did they get it so quickly?
Was it only because
they had, as I mentioned
earlier, the Nazi
Germany threat, that they
had to actually face?
And is there any way that
we could do that today?
Any way that we
could, without some
sort of evil that
we have to fight,
is there any way
that we can increase
the speed of, I don't
know, research progress
or at least the
development side of R&D,
if we can make it that quick?
CHLOE: I think, just
tagging off of MIT history
and then sort of tagging
in modern MIT history
or modern today
and MIT, but my lab
builds CubeSats that are
oftentimes funded by the Air
Force Research Laboratory.
And it's an
interesting experience
seeing the extremely short
developmental lifecycle
of these spacecraft
that are technically
supposed to be student
platform spacecraft, but still
spacecraft, being churned out in
two years, which is ridiculous.
Like, that's really fast.
And I think that that
development speed is achievable
because of the combination
of a lot of money
from the government
institution given
to an academic institution where
you have a lot of young people
who are very passionate to do
good work, who haven't been
sort of exhausted by the
industry already, you know,
their passion is still there.
There's still light
in their eyes.
And then they have the
resources to-- you know,
everyone's in one
building or, you know,
everyone can easily connect
to the resources they need.
So it's a good utilization
of funds given to people who
know how to use them quickly.
So I think that
combination works.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I think that the
Nazi threat is definitely
something that lit a
fire under the research,
leading to application
and widespread use,
but there were also a couple
of really important factors
in this particular instance.
One is that Loomis bankrolled
a lot of this stuff
by himself at the
very beginning.
And so it took the
government more years,
I think, to get behind it
financially and finally
jump on board.
And then the other
is that Loomis
can do pretty much
anything he wants,
because his cousin Stimson
just gives him this blank carte
blanche, do what you have to do.
But I think that--
I don't know.
Luis Alvarez makes a really
bold statement there,
like the last of the
amateurs of science.
I don't know.
What about Bill
Gates, for example,
is trying to do something,
I think, sort of analogous
at this point in time, with
the newer nuclear reactors
that he's trying to set up.
And he's bankrolling that
to a large degree and so--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
And he's taking
MIT online courses
in physics at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Is he really?
MAX: That's great.
AUDIENCE: And he's assembling
billionaires for this fun.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
It's another great
group, I think.
So I disagree with Luis
Alvarez on this point.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Stay tuned.
MAX: Well maybe the emphasis
in that statement is amateur,
like maybe there's a
difference between what
he defines as an amateur
and maybe Bill Gates.
Of course, it depends on
his specific definition.
Other questions that
I had included--
so someone had mentioned--
someone had asked the question,
I think it was Stimson, who
had said that he would prefer
to just stay involved
with his research,
and he really didn't want to
get involved with politics
or any sort of war effort.
So someone has-- well,
should research--
should scientists
usually just stay
in that mindset and just
mostly stay into their research
or should they get involved
in politics at all?
And I see the
advantages of both,
because on one hand, if you have
people that are only working
on research, well, they have
a unique perspective they
can contribute to politics.
But on the other
hand, that's time
they're spending away
from their research
when they could be producing
something that could be helping
people across the planet.
So I was just curious if you
guys had any thoughts on that.
RASHEED: I think
I'd probably argue
that it's pretty myopic to
say that your research has
no effect on the outside world,
in general, just because you're
studying the outside world.
That's going to exist
outside of the lab,
and it will have an
effect no matter what
you do scientifically, like say
you have your academic research
circle that's probably
directly affected.
And then if you look outside
of that, if your research is
impactful enough, you're
just going to have,
no matter what, there are
political ramifications
and everything like that
to everything you do.
And so I think
reminding scientists
to be cognizant of
those things and just
asking them to actively
take this into consideration
while they do research is
sort of necessary, just
because that's just
how the world works.
You can't really put
a drop in the bucket
and not experience
ripple effects outside.
So I think this is probably one
of the really solid examples
of why that's probably a
good thing, because you
have these people
very interested,
obviously, in the academic--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [INAUDIBLE]
RASHEED: Yeah, like the
academic implications
of radar, sort of
electromagnetism,
but also war efforts.
MAX: And I definitely
think that like
this current political
climate definitely
emphasizes why scientists should
make their opinions more known
and the consequences
of not doing that.
You had your hand
up for a while.
AUDIENCE: So I think
scientists and engineers like
to do their work as entirely
objective, like what they're
doing is like black and
white, like this is the truth
and this is not.
And I think that misses out
a lot on the social context
in which they're doing their
work and other, like the fact
that both what they're
studying and how
they study it is affected by
the world that they live in.
And so saying that they can
isolate themselves from that
doesn't seem very
realistic or effective.
AUDIENCE: I want to go back to
that point about Luis Alvarez.
I think what he meant is there's
a whole period time where it
was like [INAUDIBLE]
JJ Thomson, Tesla,
where it was like people who
just did experiments versus now
it's more academic, more
like worrying about theories
and then you do some research,
but there's people that only--
they did experiments and
they came to conclusions,
and then they built stuff
off those conclusions
about what they built.
So it's more of an organic
process of innovation.
The benefit too of Loomis
was he came from Wall Street,
so it was very fast cycle,
always getting things done.
Sometimes you step on some toes.
And so there's some benefits
to that kind of attitude,
because he thought about
it more like a business
problem in terms
of, like, oh, I'm
going to get the best people.
I can incentivize
them to be here.
And he pretty much made the
first startup incubator.
And then also, who do I need
to know to get this thing done?
Because he could have definitely
just been like, I'm rich.
I'm going to be in my penthouse
and just like take some drinks.
I don't know if he
had a wife or not.
But like--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'll
tell that story in a minute.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I assumed
there was a story there, yeah.
But it very interesting
in terms of he's
just somebody who had
to get things done.
But he just kind of
had a side interest.
And that's usually like some
of the most interesting people,
where they come from
one domain and then
they go interdisciplinary.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And that
Cavendish Lab, by the way,
is a fascinating great
group in the 1920s.
It's really fascinating.
AUDIENCE: Cavendish?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
At Cambridge.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Where
Thompson and some of the others
were.
AUDIENCE: So there's this
theory that we should think
about science more like
politics and that there's
different schools of thought.
And the problem
with science right
now is more that we only have
one way of thinking about--
you learn science one way
or you learn math one way,
whereas if you got
different perspectives,
it would make it easier
to solve problems.
And that's a very
powerful thing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I think Loomis himself
said that he thought
the scientists were
more productive focusing
on their research and
getting them off politics.
I think maybe he
almost saw himself
as kind of the
interface probably.
So as a more amateur scientist.
But he's kind of facilitating
this and making it possible.
And yeah, I think it's important
that scientists think about it.
But I guess I do agree that
they should be focused and maybe
have other people interface.
I'll be interested
to hear what goes
in it as working in the
MIT DC office that's
a large part of what
you guys do, I imagine,
just talking to the
professors here and advocating
on their behalf.
MAX: You had a comment?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, I just
had a similar point to Matt,
just like if you have an
organization with people
serving different functions,
like maybe scientists can stick
to their realm of specialty
and focus on their research
if there are other
people connecting them
to politics and outside.
MAX: I see.
STEPH: To counter, I think
about Ernie Moniz a lot.
AUDIENCE: Moniz.
STEPH: Moniz.
Moniz.
AUDIENCE: That's all right.
You've got it.
STEPH: I think of it
in the French, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You're fine.
You're fine.
STEPH: I greatly admire him.
No, I've just been looking at
this picture lovingly of him.
He's one of my heroes.
AUDIENCE: Well, tell him that.
STEPH: Please.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: He's next
door to Martha, as I recall.
STEPH: Oh, my gosh.
OK.
Even better.
I'm blushing.
Oh.
Yeah, so I totally
have a crush on Moniz.
And I think about him a lot.
So I spent--
I took a gap semester
to intern in Congress.
And one of the things
that came out of that
was becoming good friends
with the White House liaison
to the Department of Energy.
So he was one of the people
who helped pick Moniz.
And then he took me around
the office and the top floor.
I saw his office.
That was amazing.
I passed out nearly.
But the reason I
think a lot of him,
other than the fact that
I have an enormous crush,
is that he is one of those
scientists who I almost
feel like there's an immense
trade off because he became
a public servant, because
he could be doing so much
incredible work in his area
of specialty and expertise.
And at the same
time, I trust no one
but him to run the
Department of Energy, right?
And so there's that sense
that he can do what he wants,
because he is an adult expert.
And at the same time, that is an
immensely personal calculation
that he has to make about where
he feels he can make the best
contribution.
So I feel like our jobs,
not only as students taking
this course and as
stakeholders in the future
of a civil society,
as civil as it can be,
is to really consider whether
the bulk of our impact
in the world is going to be
in an arena like politics
or if we are better off
delegating that to someone else
and providing our
opinion to other people.
Because it could be that in the
coming years, as he reflects
on his tenure as Secretary
of Energy, he thinks,
well, I feel like I made
a measurable impact,
but it was for naught,
because of the ways
in which this next
administration is
going to dissolve a
lot of the efforts
that he was able to create.
So I think it'll be
interesting to hear
him give personal
feedback and maybe
more intimate conversations
with students like ourselves.
And if you do,
please let me know,
because I guess I would
hate for him personally
to feel like he gave
up so much of his life
and his productive potential to
something that is going to get
destroyed ultimately.
MAX: I was actually, like,
when you mentioned him,
I kind of started thinking--
I hadn't researched Compton
before outside of scattering,
for anyone who
doesn't know, it's
like when photons will scatter
off of electrons and atoms.
Does anyone know this?
I don't know.
So I didn't realize
before this class
that he was actually
the president of MIT.
So it makes me think
that I don't really--
at that point, I have
a parallel point--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
this guy is his brother.
MAX: I wonder-- wow,
I didn't realize--
I didn't even know
he had a brother.
There's so much about
him I don't know.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: He was
another famous physicist.
One of the all-time
great MIT presidents.
MAX: And it makes--
apparently, he was a really
good president, so that's good.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
He's credited, Max,
with bringing great
science to MIT.
MAX: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So MIT had
always had very good science,
but Compton really
embarks on an effort
to both train and find
truly fabulous science.
So MIT is positioned, frankly,
in that 1930s period when
he's president, to
be this unbelievably
capable institution with
these two sides of the story,
engineering and science,
kind of unified here.
MAX: So, Stephanie,
I would bring up
that as almost a
counter to your point,
saying that maybe it depends
on the time period, not really
the person, because I'm sure
that Moniz is really awesome.
I'm sure that he's
very articulate,
and he is certainly very
convincing in his positions.
But it probably just
depends on the timing.
So when people try to
advance whatever agenda
that they believe is best
for society as a whole.
So with Compton, I feel that
he had a lot of advantages
at the time period, like, oh,
the United States at the time
realized that we needed science
in addition to our development
capabilities.
So it definitely made
it a lot easier to--
there was a gap that
he recognized, that he
knew that could be filled.
STEPH: I'm trying to think of
a statistic about how to get
a woman to run for office.
I think it takes
something like eight times
to tell a woman
to run for office,
and she'll finally
begin considering it
in any sort of serious capacity.
And when you ask a man, it has
to be maybe one or two times
before they seriously
consider it.
And I wonder what it would
look like for scientists.
To what extent do
you have to cultivate
this paradigm of evaluating
the impact of your work
and weighing that against the
impact of your perspective and
how that can make a
difference in the world?
So I'm going to be quiet
now, because Rasheed
seems to have a point.
RASHEED: Yeah.
I'm going to argue
for form here.
So I think these guys are
all sitting around the room.
I don't know how
often this happens.
This might happen like totally
independent of the war.
These guys just get together
just because they're
so interconnected anyway.
But the point is, I think
there's an argument here
that all it really
takes is you just
have to get six or seven of
these people of this caliber
in a room, and
they'll naturally come
to the conclusion or
the idea that we need--
they'll sort of come up with a
solution for a federally funded
research institution.
And what's really
nice here, I think,
is Karl Compton is president
of MIT and then it's Bush.
Is there a president
between them?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No.
Bush is not president.
So Bush is Dean of Engineering
and then Vice President MIT.
And then he goes off to
the Carnegie Institute,
which is then a leading
scientific funding organization
based in Washington.
And he becomes Franklin
Roosevelt's science advisor
member during the war.
So he has a rich past at
MIT as a faculty member.
We'll talk about it in a minute.
RASHEED: But I think because
they're both sort of at MIT
and sort of
interconnected anyway,
you have an opportunity
to kind of transform
MIT from this great scientific
institution under Karl Compton
to sort of this federally funded
research institution, which
largely was an idea of
Bush and like a proponent.
I guess they sort of around the
table came up with the idea,
but Bush writes
this paper about it.
And then they kind of
do it under the Rad Lab
and everything.
So I think there's an argument
here that all you really need
is sort of seven
people, six or--
I'm going to say a small
group of people who have
the connections and sort of
ability to make transformations
with connections with
large research endowments,
the top facilities,
the top minds,
and then have access to just
the kind of drop-of-a-hat call,
70 scientists, and they'll all
sort of show up the next day
in a room and then say that this
is the direction we're going
to chart.
And so I'd probably argue
that, in addition to timing,
kind of access to
human capital and form
probably allows these
people to just make
decisions and kind of chart,
really, kind of drastically
new directions for
large institutions
or large universities and even
like the future of science
and technology funding in the US
and kind of make this model up.
Because it didn't really exist
before they got there, but just
get seven of them in
a room, and now you
have the Rad Lab
kind of in two weeks.
And then a day later, you
have funding from Stimson.
So I think maybe if we're
looking in the future
to do this, a group of these
people of this magnitude
or caliber could meet together
semi-regularly and come up
with ideas for how to do that.
And then maybe they don't
necessarily every single time
have to do something,
because it's not
as imminent as like Manhattan
Project or the Rad Lab,
but they probably have
some pretty good ideas
on how to reorganize things.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So we'll dive
into a lot of this
thinking when we
talk about great group theory.
So Martina, I'm going to ask
you to hold your question.
I want to wrap up Loomis,
take a quick break,
and then we'll come back.
Let me just close
out with Loomis.
What happens after the war?
He's created these
amazing institutions.
He's played an
absolutely critical role
in both getting
the Rad Lab created
and in getting Los Alamos and
then the Manhattan projects
accelerated.
It's quite a story.
We just talked
about the ideology.
He's an adherent
of conservatism.
He doesn't believe in a strong
federal-dominating kind of role
in R&D. So he and
Vannevar Bush literally,
as soon as the war ends,
dismantle the Rad Lab.
So MIT is left with this
weird wooden building.
And a fair amount of
that is Building 20.
Loomis divorces
his wife, marries
the wife of his research
director for Tuxedo Park.
They live in a Mies van
der Rohe-like glass house
on the site of Tuxedo Park.
Loomis also happens
to own Hilton Head.
So they spent a nice
time down there.
He just quietly fades.
He kind of quietly, kind of
after this amazing activist
role, and he faces a certain
amount of social ostracism
because of this
divorce, which was
considered pretty scandalous in
that era, and it affects him.
So he kind of
withdraws from society
in some interesting
kind of ways.
But he kind of
does this fade out
in places like his Mies
van der Rohe glass house
and on Hilton head.
And the Rad Lab itself, Building
20, becomes very famous at MIT,
as those of you engineers
will understand this,
but this is anything-goes space.
And it's an engineering dream.
When the returning vets
come back World War II,
this is thrown into a dormitory.
A lot of returning vets
had learned gun play
during the course of the war.
There's an old shooting
gallery in the basement.
The stories are wild.
It was made from Hurricane
of 1936 wood that
crashed all over New Hampshire,
and they just trucked it down.
This lasts for another more
than a half century at MIT.
And it's like the
wide-open experiment.
You can blow the
place up, anything
goes kind of space, which
is great in science.
I mean, you really want
some of that space where
you can do anything
and don't worry
about blowing the building
up and knocking it down.
So it becomes this great
creative center at MIT,
and lots of stuff happens there,
not quite related to science,
but Noam Chomsky
invents the whole field
of linguistics in Building 20.
AUDIENCE: Does he really?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Huh?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
Really.
It's true.
In this building.
So it's wild wide-open space.
So when Frank
Gehry is brought in
to tear this down and put the
Stata Center in its place,
he tries to preserve some of
that funky wide-open cement
open space culture to sponsor
its experimentalist feeling,
which I think he actually
does fairly successfully.
And indeed, in those wild CSAIL
laboratories behind glass,
pretty much anything
goes up there.
It's a pretty interesting space.